hello wind welcome playing Hestia off 85
91 yeah we get a king's indian my green
felt the king's indian okay so Makka
gone off yeah maybe Oh mother
thomashefsky liner currently it is
playing it so often hmm when do you go
with your night now white wants to do
that anyway queena three so that was
helpful okay um how to do that now rook
g1 is a move can also cancel wrong let's
do it let's do that back
yeah ok so this opening other everything
here I'd see Queen 2 g-3 I guess I guess
g3 is the right square pin ok so Bishop
age 3 here on a couple of interesting
interesting options yeah I think I'll
I'll go for that straight trade the
bishops and now three takes or up chicks
hmm interesting question ok let's not
spend too long
rooks probably belong on the jihad
anyway so make sense maybe to keep the g
file open okay I'm not one hundred
percent sure if a 3 is actually
attacking the night but this way i am at
least okay yeah yeah i saw it just now
it's not the end of the world that that
move but would have been nice to see it
earlier yeah should have prevented that
still this position should be quite nice
for white
yeah I can tell where the piece two
times to have some pressure or not I
don't know I think I'll do it yeah c5 is
interesting I think I'll go for that if
you take group d 7 and then winning
right he keeps playing so quickly even
in super critical positions black resign
yep okay Jim there were a lot of big fan
of black black set up here I think after
after a five that should be pretty bad
actually so what's the engine give NAT D
to you form stronger than this mood yeah
in the light of the how the game
progressed maybe that's true ma'am it's
a bit of a problem here for black
because he cannot play this as the
bishop is just hanging and I'm playing
this anyway problem is I have the open G
for this King is pretty bad I've got the
e4 Squared's it's all all a bit much I
mean this is not bad what I just what I
have to do is I have to improve now a 3
is bad that really gives them a lot of a
lot of hope this is strong
yeah that's not not strong as winning
actually oh yeah that's that's terrible
yeah like a spa city if i get to e6 then
the whole position collapses a group g1
Queen f5 and so on ok so my a3 move was
was bad I was shy as I saw this tool a
discipline chat now his position is kind
of bearable but after g6 after c6 it
gets critical again 27s given by the
computer no and now yeah now you have to
start thinking at least a little bit
it's also root g 6 in the mix Queen G to
the after c5 black is already lost but
still you can fight better than than
this to resign once in a while we have
to take a couple of seconds and actually
think about it well over over here the
aplex blackstone opening plane is very
very borderline that my Queenie age is
quite clearly not not the way to go if
you have to play the Queen again and put
yourself into a pin and already disliked
blacks position here to be perfectly
honest I think something has gone wrong
you should be should have clear a
counter player dsum anyway thanks for
watching